trouble is that once the liberalism hits
its sounded Uplands the liberal doesn't
become a conservative that that the the
kind of emancipatory dynamism of
liberalism is still there what you're
saying is progressives value change in
and of itself and they will keep
pursuing it even if they've got to a
really good point sure where do we stop
when do we stop liberating
when we stop progressing and say
actually we've done pretty well let's
just try and settle down and conserve
these games
you could have a reason a person out of
out of position that they would never
reason into and I think it's high time
for some decolonization but not not the
kind of decolonization that most people
most administrators these days have in
mind you need to recognize that ideas
age in Reverse we get weaker as we get
older ideas get stronger as they get
older barbarians are not at the gates
they've been in the city they're Manning
the citizen they've been there for quite
a while
thank you
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People can't tell you how excited we are
for our guest today he's an associate
professor at Cambridge University we've
had plenty of opportunity to speak with
him in private it doesn't do many
interviews and it is a big waste that he
doesn't because he's here Dr James or
welcome to trigonometry it's great to be
here thanks for having me it's it's an
absolute pleasure we've had so many
conversations with you just privately
over dinner or whatever in the past
various events and I've always just
thought to myself why are there no
cameras here
um because it's always really
interesting uh as you can as people
watching can tell I'm super excited to
have you uh before we get into the
conversation itself who are you uh
what's been your journey through life
how did you make it here James well
journey through life well uh born and
brought up in Brussels Brussels Belgium
where I live my early years and then was
packed off to boarding school to learn
some manners I was a pretty unruly kid
about age age nine I think and so
boarding school all the way through to
18 and then went to
now University ended up in London I was
a corporate lawyer for some years and
worked in corporate finance
um pretty pretty soul-sapping work but
um character building
and about let's have a think about 30
masking in 2009 I walked away thanks to
a very supportive and understanding wife
I left the law and became a student
again at age 30 went up to Cambridge and
started studying religion and Theology
and it did some graduate work there the
diploma a masters and then a PhD it was
a kind of a gateway drug to the life of
the Mind Graduate Studies in in religion
and then increasingly in philosophy and
questions of meaning and metaphysics and
morality and I did that up until that
sort of thing cost about 2014 when I got
the PHD then moved across to Oxford to
work with one of your previous guests I
think Professor Nigel bigger at a place
called the McDonald's Center Christ
Church Hall solution four fabulous years
I went through uh had a ringside seat
for the the Empire Wars that Nigel went
through in late 2017 2018.
and that was a something of a wake-up
call I was thinking I was sort of
politically
um uh well not naive but politically
sort of disinterested I'd say until uh
the Rumblings of this sort of new kind
of cultural revolutions started to
started to emerge on campus which must
have been I suppose about about 10 years
ago
um and then after four years there I
moved back back to Cambridge and I've
now taken up a position there as an
associate professor in philosophy
religion as I lecture in research and
philosophy religion moral philosophy
uh and those sorts of areas I'm also
um as of and just a few months ago
chairman of something called The Edmund
Burke Foundation The Edmund Burke
Foundation UK and we put on big
conferences we've got a big one coming
up on National conservatism uh in the
middle of May in Westminster and in
London uh and that's been a terrific
sort of um complement to to my main job
and something I love to do in my spare
time to sort of help to kind of catalyze
coalitions of people many of whom I
think will have appeared on your show
before talking about the Urgent issues
of our time uh from all sorts of
different political perspectives and
observing this unusual new Coalition
emerging I'm not sure quite what to call
it it's not really conservative it's not
really uh liberal
um I suppose it's it's stitched together
by a sense that there is a a uh an
emerging
world of view that is very hostile to
some of the kind of foundational
assumptions that liberals conservatives
and indeed I think old school socialists
chat uh anyway that's probably more than
you wanted to yeah it isn't but you know
the the reason I was I am so excited to
have you on is I just love like throwing
big questions at you and just see seeing
what comes up and you've already opened
one of them which is uh the thing that
I've been thinking about we've been
talking on the show about it quite a bit
which is you essentially what you've
identified is there is a threat to the
founding principles of what I would
describe Western Civilization right that
is there is a world view that seeks to
undermine and Destroy and challenge all
of that and people sort of have
coalesced around opposition to that but
now I think the next step is to go well
what is the positive alternative right
and that's something we've all I think
been wrestling you know the Jordan
Peterson Arc project and Peter thiels
talked about this and you're talking
about it so how does that happen because
you talk about how
these ideas are antithetical to the
founding principles of conservatism and
liberalism and perhaps old-school
socialism
but those people are really not going to
get on very well outside of opposing
something that's a threat yeah so how do
we have a positive view of the future
that we can all get behind well we all
share probably ultimately quite distinct
understandings of human flourishing and
the goods and virtue and so on and um
one of the one of the tragedies of a an
increasingly polarized sort of
marketplace of ideas is that we can't
really have those conversations about
the sort of differences in how we
understand uh those those kinds of
questions so I mean I think you know
one's got to try to put oneself in the
place of these uh let's call them just
radical progressives and and and
recognize that
it by their own lights they they they
are doing the right thing uh by their
own lights they've got a very clear
conception of what it is to flourish as
a human being they've got a clear
conception of uh what sin looks like
what uh what what what what moral error
looks like looks like you yeah very very
close to me
um and one of the problems obviously is
that a lot of that kind of the moral
coding rests in often contingent morally
inert physiological characteristics skin
color or Anatomy or what you want to do
between the sheets which
um historically have just not been
understood to have any any proper
bearing on on what it is to flourish as
a human being and again I think one
should recognize that it's not coming
from a a an evil place a loss of you
know the early champions of of academic
freedom and freedom of speech were from
the left and and and Champion the rights
of of minorities and wanted to expand
the franchise and so on and so forth but
as things have developed and I think
this is where I would probably depart
from maybe you uh both of you and let's
let's find out is that you know that
this is part of the Liturgy of
liberalism that this is a feature of
liberalism not a bug now my little sort
of liberal friends will say uh and as to
me as a conservative no this is
absolutely uh that this is this is not a
feature it's a bug it's a strange
aberration it's a metastasis of
liberalism it's sort of Freedom that's
just kind of you know intoxicated
Freedom it's not Liberty it's license
my suspicion and it's just a suspicion
in my position at the moment is that you
know liberalism was always going to
unravel this way
that there's something within liberalism
that is intrinsically transgressive that
is intrinsically restless and is always
chafing at the bonds of conventions
whether it's social conventions or legal
conventions and so on and so you know
you imagine uh you know the liberal has
the sort of his son lit Uplands right
that's the Horizon towards which the
moral Arc of the universe as Obama
creates Martin Luther King is is always
tending and the trouble is that once the
liberalism hits its Sun it Uplands uh
the liberal doesn't become a
conservative
you know the liberal doesn't say right
we've now got to conserve the sun lit
Uplands that that the the kind of
immense a patriot dynamism of liberalism
is still there and so they might ask
well what about
the 1.2 percent of the population of the
sunlit Uplands that would prefer the
moonless happens
what about them eh what about their
rights okay well right uh well their
rights are Paramount right and we must
now reorganize the sun it happens
to create a space that is respects the
moonlit uplanders and that means we
can't call the Upland the Sun National
moonlit anymore they're just lit
lit up so you get my you get my point
now what you're saying is progressives
value change in and of itself and they
will keep pursuing it even if they've
got to a really good place sure that's
what you're arguing that's what I'm
arguing and I didn't think you know that
I think is a plausible take on the
dynamic of liberalism I should say by
the way that conservatives have the
opposite problem yes right so if if the
central question for liberals and
progressives is liberals metastasizing
into Progressive as I say organically
and naturally is where do we stop when
do we stop liberating when do we stop
progressing and say actually we've done
pretty well let's just try and settle
down and conserve these gains
the conservatives is saying well why why
change change what do you mean change
we've got to conserve this stuff no
absolutely not and so there's a sort of
Flip Side sort of dilemma for the
conservative which the conservatives
have always had which is well you know
the world changes our environment
changes culture changes Wars happen
what's got to adapt but it's not in the
conservative DNA to sort of accommodate
change and so both sides have these sort
of you know reverse or instruct but
structurally kind of complicit problems
um and so that that that's a that's a
big challenge at the moment and so there
are some who would say look we can we
can recover liberalism we've got to see
this as a as a strange offshoot and I
don't want to say that you know
progressivism is just issues directly
it's just wholly the creature of
liberalism there are clearly other
strands I mean there is a Marxist strand
there are certain Hallmarks of the
Marxist frame of mind in progressivism
the tendency to really see the world as
split in two tiers between oppressor and
oppressed the idea that there is some a
revolution behind just just just behind
the corner that is going to set
everything to rise the idea that there
has to be you know there is a kind of uh
that Victory looks like control of the
ownership and means of cultural
production and distribution and
distribution of ideas in particular
um that's true there's also a
therapeutic element I think in the
Progressive
um uh world view that I don't know if
that comes quite from liberalism but
what you're seeing clearly is that old
school John Stewart Mill type liberalism
you know that rests on things like the
no harm principle you know I'm free to
do whatever I want provided you know my
my freedom to act stops you know my my
fists Freedom stops at your at your nose
and so on and so forth I mean what's
happened there is I think quite an
interesting phenomenon and it's
described by a chap called what's his
name Nicholas Haslam is an Australian
psychologist it's called concept group
and we're familiar with it once you see
it you can't unsee it but particularly
the concept creep around language of
harm violence care kindness and so on
and it's sort of the positive side as
well
and effectively what's happened is that
Mills principle I think as harm has
become increasingly psychologized and as
we've come to the view that you know
hurting words damage you and
disagreement is there's just tantamount
personal assault then Mills sort of
principle get liberalism can get
weaponized and say well that means we
now have appropriate restrictions or not
just on everything you say but really on
everything you think because
restrictions on what you say will affect
the way you think and this is something
we're seeing obviously in the academy
right across the English-speaking world
and to some extent in in Continental
Europe though perhaps it's it's less
aggressive over there
um
so yes I mean that so what is very very
tempting particularly when you work like
I do in sort of a history of ideas to
say well this particular social
phenomena is obviously rooted to you
know obviously emerges from that
philosopher's study things are just not
as simple as that and um I think we
sometimes overstate or rather ignore
um the contingent in uh human Affairs
and in history so you know there's
always you know this talk on the on the
internet about being being white filled
or black pills you know have you got a
positive thing about the view of the
future which you seem to you you
envisage a post-work world uh or do you
have a negative uh sort of view of the
future and I think that's you know
that's simply underplays just how random
uh history uh randomly history unfolds I
mean imagine yourself
at a dinner party in Berlin
in January 1989 a Spam party or whatever
they had for dinner in Berlin in 1989
and imagine someone turning to you and
saying
in 10 months
all this will be over
it'll all be gone
and I think people would have thought
you were you were completely mad I mean
there were certainly signs that the
Soviet regime was creaking and he was
seeing some Insurrection movements here
and solidarity in Poland harvell in the
checks the interest back and so on but
the idea that suddenly it would just be
just go was it was almost unthinkable
and I think similarly today I mean just
this is probably grish to your Mill
concert in with your remark you know
what are we going to do what do we how
do we think constructively one of the
one of the things we need to start
thinking constructively is Hope
you know the sense that it will come to
an end and let's get started on building
the alternative that's going to take its
place and that's a very hard thing to do
when things look grim and particularly
when they look kind of structurally grim
um when laws and and Institute the whole
institutional landscape of of the west
or much of it seems
sort of hypnotized sort of mesmerized by
the identitarian agenda
um so yeah that's uh take the gray pill
James you spoke and that was a
forensically brilliant analysis of where
we find ourselves you omitted one thing
that considering your background and
your area of study I found a little bit
surprising in that you didn't mention
the religious elements yes yeah
I didn't mention the religious element
because I think the comparison between
progressivism and this new forms of sort
of pathological forms of progressivism
and religion can be wildly overstated
um I mean religion itself is notoriously
indeterminate concept that uh uh and and
you know colleagues who work in religion
uh say this often that a certain sort of
definitional criteria for religion that
will just Encompass virtually everything
including things that we wouldn't
normally associate identify as a
religion
um loving the Chelsea Football Club can
it has all the trappings of a kind of
cult
um a belief based entirely on faith
there we go there we go that's right
that's right yeah and they get a bit
angry when you contribute
and and Converse you can restrict the
definition of religions so you know in
in sort of you know in such a narrow way
that it's you cease to have any sense of
you know the things that you would want
to include as a religion say for example
Mahayana Buddhism do you want to include
as a religion that that you know you
can't if you Define religion and by
orientation to a god for example
um nevertheless as I said you know I
think there are certain homework well a
certain sort of trappings of of uh
progressivism that that probably
probably could you probably could
identify as as religious and I do think
that once a kind of common inheritance
leaves a society particularly dissolves
relatively quickly as we've seen
particularly in the west certainly in
the UK over the last 30 40 50 years that
does create a vacuum nature a port the
natural world oppose a vacuum the
spiritual World Applause a vacuum and by
spiritual I don't mean sort of woo-woo
spiritual you may just be a
card-carrying atheist but you still will
recognize that religion is a real
phenomenon in in human history and
you'll recognize that actually
modernity is engaged in a kind of very
large uncontrolled
experiments in seeing how we can get on
large large societies can function
without that one the one thing that all
human societies up until in a scheme of
human history five minutes ago
had as Central was the sort of glue that
tied a society together and it ties a
society together not through laws but by
commanding as it were a source of moral
Authority that it pre that is pre
basically pre-political I mean that's
the fundamental uh advantage of religion
I mean I think I think it was Talib
Nicholas Naseem Talib who he drew the
analogy of saying you know just you know
restaurants charge you you know get you
in with the food and and get your money
with with the booze and he says well
religion's a little bit like that you
know it gets you in with all of these
beliefs but really it's giving you the
rules you know and it's giving you these
sort of unspoken often are not
inarticulated extra legal conventions
guard rails a sort of social fabric
that's very very difficult almost
impossible for any government or any
Central authority to to legislate
um and it said certainly kind of
inculcates I think particularly in the
abrahamic Traditions particularly in the
hebraic and then the Christian
Traditions it's got there are certain
sort of you know codes that operate on
the basis of very clear prohibitions and
commands to do certain things I mean
compare the Greek tradition the Greek
tradition you know Aristotle let's say
nothing in excess Med and Ag and just
you know don't overreach yourself you
know the gods will strike you down but
you know love your friends hate your
enemies and so on but it's all sort of
moderation whereas the sort of you know
the decalogue is Thou shalt not you know
and it can seem particularly as a
liberal context as rather sort of
intimidating and terrifying an
absolutist but as you know looking at
religion as an evolutionary phenomenon
interdicts prohibitions blankets
prohibitions blanket sort of commands
like that a much cleaner and clearer
they're easier to pass on they're easier
to inherit they are much easier to apply
in large sort of complex across large
complex population
um so religion does have a bearing
absolutely and I think that you know if
we are going to try and find some
constructive vision of the way forward
there does need to be some maybe it
doesn't need to be a religious one I
mean maybe there is something we've
missed maybe there is a kind of Dewey
eyed
dawkinsian humanism that we can sort of
all kind of share and just agree to to
live by
um and and and and sort of get on but I
think the last 56 years has shown that
that in the absence of these very very
sort of complex belief systems
um uh others other sort of you know
crude assistance of of um moral
accountability and so on begin to begin
to creep in
um so I mean and I think there's a
difference you know a society that is
let's say broadly speaking shares it
exists in the same moral Universe with
roughly speaking of the same assumptions
about what counts as right and wrong
what counts as a flourishing human being
and some and and a human being that that
is suffering I mean that that doesn't
mean that you need to be a theocracy I
mean it doesn't mean that you need you
know even even more than you know half
the population believing any of the
stuff you can still as it were as I know
you know many atheists who are much more
aggressive 15 years ago during the the
sort of the new atheist Revolution I
mean a lot of atheist friends I have
from actually one of the things that got
me interested in religion in the first
place I'm very grateful to that law but
I mean a lot of my atheist friends were
much more aggressive back in those days
now I mean they're still atheists a lot
of them some of them are not actually
some of them moved over to the other
side a lot of them say gosh yeah I I can
see I I can see what the effects are of
leaving this stuff behind I think Ross
doubt it has a line somewhere in the
American context you know if you didn't
like the religious right just wait till
you see the post religious right
and actually you know and I think you
can say that on the left too you know if
if you didn't like the kind of um you
know religiously settled Christian
socialist left or whatever you know just
wait till you see the the hard kind of
you know Fabian Fabian Marxist left do
you think we've become and particularly
I'm glad you brought up the new atheist
movement because one of sort of their
Central tenants was we don't really need
religion it served its purpose it's you
know it was awful it did all these
unspeakably vile things people suffered
as a result
we've moved beyond that yeah yeah and
that was always a pretty naive argument
I mean I'm in the not not that they were
I mean there weren't a lot of naive
arguments but for by the new atheist in
my view but that was just you know any
any
one with a passing familiarity of the
history of the 20th century just just
couldn't
he was saying oh yeah well thank
goodness once we passed religion we're
we're we'll be fine you know look how
well look how well the atheists behave
that's right and then what would happen
is things would descend this is
particularly when you're arguing about
uh Christopher hitchens's book um God Is
Not Great you get into this awful
situation where you know you're sort of
trading genocides oh well you know I you
know think of what what sort of
proportion of the of the of the
population of the Americas was was
slaughtered as a result of you know
um uh uh sort of Catholic imperialism or
whatever it might be and and we'll look
at look at how many how many did
Starling kill I mean and it's just all
got very unseemly and and both sides
missed the point there which is
the a very as clear a data point as
human history offers up namely that what
is soldier knitson's line the line
between good and evil does not fall
between Asian States but goes right
through the human heart and so the
question is what is the correct analysis
of The Human Condition how is it that we
we produce a Hitler and a Mother Teresa
and now that that's a philosophical
question
the secular humanist answer to that is
well evil is just a kind of some sort of
aberration you know basically human
beings are all you know cuddly teddy
bears provided provided they are
Unshackled
from the the chains of of water whatever
oppressor liberalism is is chafing
against sometimes that was that was good
I mean there were genuine liberal
victories and and important ones but as
I said earlier now we're getting the
point where a lot of those just it is
almost Unthinkable for a certain
liberal-minded Progressive to accept
that limits can be liberating
I mean this is a key conservative
Insight that that we all know deep down
I mean I drove here today I I couldn't
have got here had it not been for the
fact that there's a dense web of
conventions and rules and laws that are
that are limits that are at one level
seen from one point of view constraints
on my agency
now but then all constraints are I mean
there are constraints on my agency but
they're constraints that enabled me to
get here without really worrying about
it or thinking about it and that is
something that it it it's quite
difficult to accept when we have a view
of the South as basically autonomous
this is the sort of liberal
Enlightenment view we're free we're
autonomous we pop into the world yeah we
may love our mums and that sort of thing
but basically you know we're on our own
we're all we're autonomous and any
obligations that we might find ourselves
sort of caught up in need to be freely
entered into
we must give our consent to obligation
obligations can really only arise if we
choose them
now that seems to be plainly false and
sort of the conservative critique of
that is I mean of course not yeah I mean
not only do you love your mum what is
conquests first law he's got three laws
or the first one is
everyone is conservative about what they
know best right you're going to be
conservative about your kids there are
certain things but you're gonna let you
know you'll be happy you know this is
Rob my friend Rob edinson's beliefs I
think you've had him yeah his luxury
beliefs idea you know it's you can be
you can you can be a conservative about
what you know best and then you know you
don't care about how you're sort of out
of the policeman might trickle through
into into wider Society so
um that that idea that limits can be
liberating that freedom that true
Freedom should be not just raw Freedom
not just raw license but somehow ordered
and downstream of
basically
non-liberal I wouldn't say illiberal but
non-liberal
forms of human life I mean what are the
three apps three hours Faith Family flag
and that's the sort of convenient way of
putting it that's the orders because it
says faith first family second flag the
moral Community the nation state could
be a city-state
um it could be you could be in the
United States or into being a sort of
Federated a federal state once those
three are in place then freedom freedom
flows well Freedom functions
freedom is orders a little bit like you
you see this argument with in in the
free markets with you know Hayek and
others you know you you there's you
can't just have complete Anarchy they've
got to be constraints and in fact you
want the constraints in order for the
freedom to be conducive to flourishing
hey KK do you like trigonometry of
course I do incredible interviews
fascinating guests phenomenal live shows
and hilarious raw streams in that case
you need to join our locals so you can
have access to even more brilliant
content that's right you get the chance
to win incredible prizes ask our
phenomenal guests your questions access
extra content and now the only place to
watch our Roars on catch up is on locals
are all shows still go out at 7 pm UK
time 2 p.m Eastern as normal but if you
want to watch them after this time then
you're gonna need to sign up to our
locals Ross have now become too spicy to
stay on YouTube so they're only
available to watch back on our locals
page all you need to do to sign up is
click on the link below this video and
for just seven dollars a month you have
access to All of This brilliant content
seven dollars a month even for someone
of my persuasion that's a bargain see
you all on locals
I suppose the not that I want to delve
too deeply into this but the immediate
pop-up in my head was the obvious
counter to that is
if Faith flag and family is what
produces Freedom the progressive counter
argument to that is but not for the
moonlit uplanders
right that version of Freedom that
you're talking about the progressive
argument is is freedom for someone who
looks like you yeah but it's not freedom
for someone who looks like me it's not
freedom for someone who's gay or trans
or whatever and it's freedom for the
majority to the exclusion of the
minority yeah absolutely right that
that's the that's the standard that's
the standard critique and uh and it's
true sometimes it's a well-founded
critique that
um certain expressions of religion here
Hitchens isn't wrong about some of the
examples he uses
um and and so and some expressions of of
nationalism in the past and patriotism
in the past have in indeed led to you
know not nasty forms of Oppression but I
think that
um the issue is you know do you have not
not just do you inherit the moral norms
and moral reflexes of your faith or or
your family or or your flag but what is
what is the best way of structuring a
society so bad everyone you you can that
can be maximal flourishing for all and
so that means that at the level of the
state
or the level of the sort of central
authorities there has to be as it were a
degree of procedural neutrality and
liberalism is right about this
particularly if you're organizing large
large complex societies they have to be
certain principles that are uh
principles which are uh blind to
um nationality in certain contexts that
are blind to your family structure that
uh that don't take your religion into
account I think the trouble with a lot
of those critiques is that they assume
um precisely what they think they're
criticizing namely that those features
do matter the the rule of law should not
be should not apply to war well of
course that's why I oppose workness so
much because it's obvious that it's a
reversal of that very liberal principle
yeah the liberal principle that everyone
should be treated as an individual yeah
who's worthy and has value is being
reversed by the idea that some people's
skin color makes them less worthy or
more worthy than others it's absurd but
I want to come back to a couple of the
things you said James because you use
the word that I've heard used before but
the way you used it lit about a bunch of
light bulbs I mean you talked about
pre-political
and I think that therein lies the answer
to all of this which is we have to have
something that we all agree on basically
now
let's put God to one side because we
don't all agree about that it's just a
fact whether you'd like that or to be
different or I'd like that whatever
what do we have left that is
pre-politically
agreed on in our society because for
some time I thought that maybe it's you
know Western values or British values
but you walk up to the random person on
the street you're asking what British
values are they're going to run away
from you right so what do we have left
that is pre-political
well I would say increasingly little or
at least the the sort of engines that
drove our kind of
um that that produce the glue that
stitches together in a way that
transcended the sort of mechanisms of
states and law and and so on
um our are under attack and and I think
this is basically because there's been a
shift to thinking of all pre
political domains as intrinsically
political
um and like family sorry to interrupt
but this is such a good example because
for me a new father the idea that having
a family and children blah blah is like
a self-evident truth that that is
something a society's inevitably built
around and if You observe a society you
can't you can't deny that that's not
true but there are people to whom the
very notion of even advocating for the
idea of family being Central to society
is a political statement that they find
a problem because it excludes the
moonlit of London right yeah yeah
absolutely right so there can be no uh
there is no kind of non-political
Dimension to to human life
and and this is something which you know
again I think is a you know it's a
broadly religious idea this is this is a
thesis not about the state not about
public policy but about the way the
world is and so there's nothing within
the world that escapes the system the
system of Oppression the system of of of
of of of kind of um uh our sort of
structural captivity and
um you know at now at one level
it's not wrong I mean Aristotle has a
famous line in in politics that that man
is a politic on zone is a political
animal right by which he means he's an
animal that belongs to the police that
is the animal that is not designed to be
to exist alone like we're all we are to
that extent all political we're all part
of a moral Community but we've got to
negotiate our participation in that in
all sorts of different in all sorts of
different ways but yes that's right I
mean I think you you've now got a a
situation where there can be no
pre-political everything even you know
configurations of family and
understanding of family life uh faith is
now seen as freighted with
um uh you know the ideologically
problematic assumptions or often faith
is seen as an opportunity to sort of you
know Drive uh drive a kind of truck
right through uh sort of establish the
established conventions that the faith
it had built up
um so you know it is it's it's a real
struggle and I think probably one of the
reasons that conservatives tend to do so
badly in a lot of these struggles is
that politics isn't everything
um politics is not something that um
you're gonna do at the weekends
um that it's that it's um
hopefully or as I see on the other side
there is a kind of actually sometimes
you know morally remarkable investment
in the political so it just dominates
every every every aspect of of as that
those those activists lives that it's
it's that it's that important and there
there can be no weekends in the in the
struggle to to to liberate ourselves
from tyranny and so yes you haven't run
off and you know joined the convent or
jumped off a cliff or whatever from
which I deduce that you do believe
something can be done about this
yes because you're still doing stuff I'm
still I'm still doing stuff and a lot
and and loving it and I'm you know happy
and free and and I'm doing you know work
work that I love with with people I I
love spending time with
um I I think I'm fortunate I'm in a
remarkable University that has been
through some spasms and
um here and there but broadly speaking
when you look across the landscape
certainly of higher education across the
West certainly over the other side of
the Atlantic uh a place like Cambridge
is is still
um very much a place where you can uh
speak freely not not many people maybe
share the views that I share but
um and there can be some um some
resistance to it sometimes but broadly
speaking it's a it's a it's a it's a
function more than a functioning
institution and it's an institution in
which one can one can live in
intellectually and and professionally
flourishing
um uh uh life
um but yeah I mean that there is this
you know I think they're broad sometimes
I think that you know people who are you
know pessimistic about the consequences
of this
Revolution uh sometimes think you're
sort of in like a little bit like you're
in the 1520s just instead of right after
the Reformation you broadly had three
strands you had the sort of lutherans or
early lutherans anyway I thought well we
can reform this in it the institution is
bad but we can reform it from within
just you know give us a bit more time
bit of diplomacy bit of organizing we'll
you know we'll regain the universe we'll
regain the University or regain this
institution
and then I think there's a more radical
strand that says nah it's over you know
we're done here we need to build
parallel institutions I think you're
seeing this in the United States just
doing sort of some to some degree a kind
of sorting mechanism a sorting pattern
and sort of been into the red States and
the blue States and that's the kind of
calvinist option you know we need a
Geneva so we're fed up with bro we need
Geneva we'll start again and I sometimes
think there's a third Strand and I think
of these as what I call the digital
anabaptists so the anabaptist said you
know now the problem is institutions
full stop
and we need we need networks that we
need to operate and we can only flourish
and operate outside the institutions and
I actually see what you guys are doing
to be not to sort of fall into that
third strand you are you know you've got
enormous influence and reach and you
talk you're you're engaged in a lot of
these discussions and matters but but in
a completely non-institutional mode and
that's actually been very very effective
particularly uh in the in this new
digital Public Square where which opens
up all sorts of you know interesting
kind of opportunities and Dynamics so
I'm you know I'm I'm in the first Camp
because I think in Cambridge you know
all is all is not lost by any means and
I think the same is true of Oxford
if I were in some other universities in
this country and certainly if I were as
many universities in the United States I
think I probably would say
um
Barry Weiss Neil Ferguson are spot on
they need to we need to you know start
something new all my friends Stephen
Blackwood who started Ralston college or
we needed we need separate institutions
I just got back from Hillsdale College
it was hosted by the great larian the
president of Hillsdale College just a
small classical liberal arts Christian
college but it's a remarkable place and
uh just just sticking to you know the
Western Canon is pretty ecumenical not
not denominational do you know and and
is is doing fantastic work
um
and then you know and I admire and
support people who want to build that
build their new genevas
um and admire and support those who are
operating outside the institutions in
what you might call networks I mean this
is Neil's um Square on the tower
distinction which I find very helpful I
mean a lot of people are thinking you
know the idea is that you know the the
tower is the way we tend to look at
history you know big institutions popes
Kings Great Men Etc
um whereas in fact a lot of the drivers
of historical change and cultural change
economic change are operating in in the
Square Down Below in the marketplace
through through networks that are
largely invisible to the naked eye of
the historian
um that they're just harder to it's
harder to see you know you can't you can
trace the history of institution much
more easily than you can trace the the
the the development of a sort of network
of you know friends and and and you know
patterns of Correspondence and so on and
so forth but I think increasingly you
know the good that that is to come and I
do believe is is around the corner will
be those sort of networks in the Square
as it were or perhaps networks that end
up in the tower
um and there's something that there's a
huge advantage to networks I think and
um you know they're much more flexible
they can adapt much more rapidly to
changing circumstances networks
accommodate disagreement very well you
know if you're sort of a couple people
fall out like or two important people in
it you know fall out that can be a
disaster for an institution institution
splits there's schisms and so on and so
in a network you just sort of you know
rearrange the nodes a bit maybe cut a
couple off but you know it's very very
sort of adaptable it changes
the trouble is I mean institutions you
know have this Legacy that can that can
go Way Beyond
um you know the lifetimes of its members
whereas networks are much more dependent
on on on on on on its people on the
people who make it up which is not a bad
thing I mean you know it's it's uh the
good thing about networks is that
they're they're easier to trust I mean
you know I think it's more likely that
the British museum is going to go woke
probably has gone well he's very woke I
was there a couple of months ago and I
was staggering oh what I saw right so
more likely the British museum to go
very likely there was a museum
then you Francis that is to say you know
people are much harder to capture in
that way whereas institutions remarkably
are we've seen this with astonishing
speed
um and that puts conservatives in a
funny you know paradoxical situation
because the instinct is to conserve but
why would we want to conserve capture
you know we do you know don't like
burning things down
but what happens when maybe you know you
you do need to go off and do something
else you need to just say look this is
got to the point where you know this is
an institution that's hostile to me and
hostile to all the values I hold I hold
dear and I think hostile to the founding
vision of the people who set it up and
have been stewarding it over time but I
you know we could I'm not going to spend
my money and my time trying to keep it
going and change it from within and that
puts conservatives in a very difficult
position or at least people with small C
conservative instincts and they're not
natural reaction rate it's not you know
they don't like the barricades
um so yeah that that's um that those are
that some sort of spread of options as
as I see them and um different people
are sort of attuning them tuning
themselves into to different ones and
James and what would you say to those
people who go look
everything that happens in America we
ingest we we take and then we we just
apply it and we've seen it look how bad
things are over there look about it
things are for instance at Columbia
University which are talking about
getting rid of the SATs as a as a way of
assessing a a student's academic ability
yeah I mean this is inevitably what's
going to happen here isn't it
so I I agree I mean I agree that we are
largely operating within our
institutions and within our culture and
within to some extent our policy making
with a dare I said a colonized mindset
um and and I think it's high time for
some decolonization but not not the kind
of decolonization that most people most
administrators these days have in mind
in the UK that is to say we we've lost
our our sense of what it is to be
um uh which I say to be British but at
least to to emerge from this particular
moral Community with its this particular
history this particular makeup of people
these particular Traditions uh yes
demographically were very different but
we're very different mainly because a
lot of people have come over to live
here since the second world war because
they love this rainy little island for
some reason and it's not because it's
not the rain and it's not the food you
know that there's some reason that some
things attract them overhand it's not
because it's America it's something
different
um and so we we've lost that I mean I
think there there is a sense that it is
quite extraordinary that
um I was talking to
an academic about this the other day it
is quite extraordinary that the death of
a man tragic death of a man in a foreign
city five thousand miles away
can lead within 48 hours
to that academic being asked about the
skin color of the authors on his
undergraduate reading list
I mean that is
that is an ideology working at such
speed and in such lockstep but it's very
very hard to know how to respond to it
or let alone you know resist it
um
and again I think people with
conservative instincts sort of
structural disadvantage here why because
conservatives are conserving this is a
this is a you know a familiar point that
conservatives are conserving their own
particular Traditions their own
particular laws and language and
literature and religious expressions and
so on and so you know the Communists the
the Soviets used to have a common term
short for communist International was
founded in 1919 as such a movement that
tried to implement this idea of workers
of the World Unite it was an
intrinsically cross-border
universalizing movement and similarly
today you could step you could say you
know worksters at the world
unite I mean there's just it has got a
sort of transnational appeal well let's
add some Nuance to that James because I
don't I don't think that's actually
entirely true compared to the common
term because the common turn idea was
for communism to work everybody gets it
right like otherwise you're going to
have places that are better and then
it's not going to work but with with
wokeness it is a uniquely anglo-sphere
phenomenon now it is leaking out you
know I did an interview for a German
newspaper today like people are but
generally it's an Anglers Fair
phenomenon why are we so vulnerable to
this mind virus in the anglo-sphere well
I mean go back to what I suggested
earlier that you know if I'm right that
this is a feature of liberalism not a
bug then you would expect yes the
um feature to emerge in that part of the
world where liberalism has been dominant
um so uh I think that's got a lot to do
with it
um and if you then marry that to
the culture of the therapeutic which we
haven't really talked that much about
but you know that the emergence of homo
psychologicus you know the idea that
human beings are primarily to be
understood in terms of their sort of
psychological uh balance and so on that
if you if you throw that into the mix if
you throw in some of the sort of
Protestant Evangelical impulses that
again are quite sort of you know broadly
particular historically at least
distinct distinctive to the
English-speaking world then you've got a
kind of heady mix
that that I think explains quite
naturally why okra this kind of
metastasized progressivism has emerged
in English-speaking World rather than
anywhere else
um but as with the other kind of
Institutions and ideas that we exported
um you know rule of law and habeas
corpus etc etc
um it seems that this one also has has
um export potential has export Financial
potentially exactly right but why does
it why is this idea so powerful because
you're a philosopher you deal in the
world of ideas why is this idea so I
mean people compare it to a virus to me
it's almost a cliche now but when I was
working in the comedy industry I was in
it pre-work we both were and then all of
a sudden we just saw it spread and not
just infect the industry all the
comedians but also audiences as well so
why are the ideas so powerful I mean
partly perhaps because it's we've
shifted these ideas have shifted from
the kind of normal sort of sphere of the
political to what you might call the
biopolitical that is to say these issues
now affect
um what it is to be to be me now you
could imagine back in the 1970s you
always had this big ding dong between
left and right over say you know you
know the the intervention by the state
or or the degree of ownership the means
of production and economic distribution
and so on and so forth
now debates have shifted to issues that
at least one side thinks pertain to the
constitutive elements in in a person's
identity
that one sexual orientation for example
one skin color or one's Anatomy or
whatever it might be it actually belongs
to you know is is what I am
and therefore any uh disagreement with
it uh isn't just disagreement with a
lifestyle or a set of political ideas
but is somehow
uh an objection to me and so this is
where you get these sort of strain this
strange language you hear on campus of
you know Eurasia you're erasing my
existence or or My you know and to talk
of of bodies you know bodies are sort of
Science of of
um
of of moral of a moral focus and it's
it's a language that can you know sound
very strange to to our ears but that's
what's going on this is this this is the
biopolitical and this makes disagreement
almost always
turn into or be seen as
um a kind of assault a kind of a kind of
an attack I mean Evangelical Christians
you you they have this this motto
um what was it hate the sin Love The
Sinner this is the idea well then you
heard this on this in the same sex
marriage debates in the United States
whenever it was 10 years ago you know we
we we love all people we love all people
but those certain activities that we
find to be morally objectionable and not
conducive to human flourishing this is a
sort of for many years this was just a
sort of normal distinction to draw
the arrival of identity politics meant
that it was impossible
to hate the sin and love the sin and
hating the sin meant hating The Sinner
because the sin was just as it were
under what was understood as the sin was
just intrinsic to what a person what a
person was so that really ramps up the
you know ramps up the
sort of decibel levels of public debate
and if you then add to the mix this sort
of therapeutic shift from sin to
syndrome
where you know my what were previously
seen as forms of life were activities or
acts that were evaluable in moral terms
and negatively sort of condemned in
moral terms but are now somehow you know
where they're not welcome are not
actually you know not actually my fault
but but due to the sort of certain forms
of psychological oppression that I've
been subjected to
you you've there got a sort of a recipe
for kind of the deep kind of tectonic
disagreement that that is almost just
impossible to Bridge and this is why we
see the dialogue of the death that
you've seen so much of you that you guys
picked up on
almost you know earlier than almost
anyone in on the comedy circuit
and James
I suppose the one thing we haven't
talked about and you mentioned the
Reformation I mean the Reformation is a
product to some extent of the changing
nature of the media environment to put
it you know very fancifully from what it
was you know the ability for people to
read more uh and uh for the fact that
not only the church could print
information for people to read that
changed the entire landscape you get
centuries of religious War blah blah
blah
and it seems to me at least like we've
just lived through another Revolution
and we are still living through another
revolution of exactly the same kind and
I would argue and I'm interested to hear
your opinion
that the fact that we live online as
much as we do now means that ideas that
sound good but are practically not true
will reliably outperform ideas that
sound bad but are practically more true
and I would argue that a large reason
why this spread of this ideology is
coincided with the spread of social
media online communication is that you
know work ideas sound great
yeah there's there's a lot to that and
that they've got a kind of uh
self-sustaining energy and and appeal
and that the emergence of the digital
digital Public Square and digital means
of communication has just sort of you
know
um uh made the the you know it just
accelerated uh um the the kind of
transmission of these different ideas
and accelerated to the dissolution of
all of those
um bonds that would hold a society
together
um and you know and you see and there's
a kind of capitalist I mentioned to this
too you know as as markets become more
liquid then that's going to have you
know subversive effects on a settled
moral community that is broadly
tradition based
that's not always a bad thing I mean you
know and and it has you know ownership
and and capital and and employment can
have subversive effects which are not
you know not necessarily bad effects I
mean I think of you know maybe a
traditional African communities and you
know it's hard to be patriarchal when
your daughter's earning more than you
for example
um so yes I mean but I think you're
you're right to compare it to the
Reformation I mean I think it's
it it what we're seeing at the moment I
think what we're living through is of
that order of magnitude I think it's
that sort of epocal a shift both in
terms of technology and in the
reconfiguration of
um public space and the marketplace of
ideas that it's bringing about uh partly
because it's I mean it's dissolving the
marketplace
um and this is this is something that is
very very difficult for conservatives to
cope with because you know the the the
the the the the sort of the
conservatives had basically worked out
how to conserve what they wanted to
conserve but these acids are just far
more powerful than than they're able to
hit then they're able to to deal with
and so that's why you're seeing as it
were uh uh the sort of phenomena that
held people together whether it's Faith
or whether it's ordinary you know normal
ordinary family structures or
allegiance to a combination state or
just allegiance to you know your local
Town your local Village all of that has
now sort of gone out the window and so
there's a kind of you know there's a
there's a there's an asymmetry as it
were the technology has sort of
accelerated the asymmetry between those
who value what's near and dear who want
to owe their devote their affections to
basically to the local or to the land or
to this country rather than the world it
makes it very very hard for to kind of
sustain that to make that idea appealing
um and uh so so this is yeah I mean that
that's no doubt at all that the
technology is driven you know has made
these ideas sort of a lot more
attractive and as as sort of accelerated
this brand
also part of the problem as well that
conservatism simply isn't cool James and
look I'll give you an example of this if
you think of any of the great artists
we'll take music for example
particularly the last 50 or 60 years the
great artist David Bowie the
transgressive yeah they were Progressive
yeah they
subverted societal Norms they played
with what we know to be
you know the Norms as as I said before
conservatives are never going to do that
because they intent on keeping things as
they are and isn't that the problem as
well that i i people ask me where are
conservative comedians of course there
are some comedians who are conservative
but the vast majority and the people who
are attracted to the Arts are themselves
Liberal Liberal by Nature because they
have open-mindedness they're Progressive
they want things to change and by the
way even in this country the the
comedians who you would say are
conservative Jeff norcop yeah really
isn't a conservative Leo curse really
isn't the consignment Evans you know
like these are people who are you know
they they they're not on the left but
they're not they're not sitting there
saying we must conserve what we are like
yes they still have a a kind of
counter-cultural or at least you know
unorthodox views about the world they're
not trying to preserve everything
exactly rigidly as it is there's a
wonderful line by Scottish po whose name
Escape me for the time being and he says
let me write the songs of a nation and I
cannot who writes its laws
and there's no doubt that culture
whether it's artistic creation has a
kind of binding effect is it able to
elicit the desires and the loyalties and
the feelings
of of people far far better than the
kind of you know the alternative far far
better than the kind of you know rules
and traditions and going to church or
whatever it might be
so you're right there is there is a
problem there
um feelings don't care about your facts
you know and and the people who are best
able to excite and Quicken your feelings
are the ones who have got an advantage
I suppose what I'd say is that there's
been there has been a sort of
boomeranging effect that you guys have
lived through and you've witnessed and
and Jeff and others as an assignment
have witnessed yes you're right that the
conservatives weren't able you know sort
of at least recently I'm gonna say it's
always been true but you know the last
50 60 years when artistic Freedom has
been associated with political Freedom
it's often very effective in powerful
ways
but since since the the dawn of that
kind of fusion uh is is absolutely true
the conservatives have been on the back
firm but what are we witnessing now what
we're witnessing now is uh just as much
I'd say far more
sterility and sameness in autistic
production and in comedy and music and
TV dramas and films I mean I was just
looking you know looking down the Oscars
list the other day and I realized that
the last time I'd seen a film actually
seen a film at all that had won best
Arts go was I think 2014 and 2013 2014
it was 12 years of today I think it was
um and so it's not as if you know a a
kind of broadly liberal kind of
transgressive momentum is
um is is doesn't itself have negative
you know blowback effects and so we're
now in this strange position where
um you know autistic genius has been
sort of desiccated partly because
novelty is is discouraged and and you
know the ideological lockstep demands uh
Innovation only in in the ornamental
um there's any Orthodoxy sorry there's a
new Orthodox there is a new Orthodoxy
and it's an Orthodoxy that has to be
conserved at all costs
um and so there is a kind of you know
and that conservation involves
um excluding any any sort of dangerous
ideas or any new ways of expressing
things that might go against or cut
against the grain of the ideology that's
being that's being conserved
um and you might say that you know one
talks about conservatism and liberalism
I mean really these are you know they're
parasitic terms I mean liberalism just
you know there's always the second
question that needs to come or freedom
for what you know what kind of freedom
freedom to do what
any any kind of freedom is that what
you're sort of basing your whole world
view on and same with the conservative
conserving what I mean it's an
intrinsically kind of parasitic idea
what you're conserving where you want to
be a conservative in Berlin in 1943 you
want to conserve that nobody not
obviously not
um so this is where you have it you know
do you see this interesting and quite
interesting but often quite uh anemic
debate in academic Department political
departments political philosophy
departments and also among with among
politicians between between
conservatives and and liberals because
you know you know the thought is that
conservatism is basically you know
conserving the fruits of the previous
Revolution you know and um and that
conservatism is a kind of you know
hesitation within liberalism it's sort
of liberalism at the speed limit you
know that there isn't something
prior and and deeper that that's being
conserved that comes before the
enlightenment actually
um and now I think that's true and I
think that a lot of you know
conservatives more people who think that
they can serve is coming after uh the
enlightenments see themselves as as
basically you know conserving liberalism
from you know a couple of centuries ago
I mean Roger scrutin is a great of whom
I am an enormous admirer
um and and was fortunate enough to know
him towards the end of his life I mean
he he is like this I mean he says that
you know he's basically a county and
everything before can't is just you know
Confusion And Delay and all this you
know strange God stuff and all these
sort of medievals etc etc
um really it all begins there but but
let's just you know let's go slow drive
at the speed limit
um
so
yeah I mean this this back and forth is
is helpful but I think what we're seeing
now
um is the emergence of something very
very different and uh in a in a funny
way you might have seen this a kind of
Coalition between liberals and
conservatives from the sort of post-war
or you know during the war and Beyond
the war where effectively you couldn't
really tell the difference between these
two broad constituencies broad sort of
ideological families because there was a
common enemy uniting them in in in in
Marxism Marxist leninism and then you
have this sort of strange sort of
unraveling period between the early 90s
and let's say 2010 a sort of Golden Era
which you know I went through school and
University and there's you know what we
all thought you know you know end of
history and the sort of uh uh uh and the
kind of the dusk of all kind of
political conflict and all of that but
in fact that was just a you know it was
a pause and there's a new
religion and new outlook that is that is
that is emerging now which is creating
once again a kind of very strong
alignment between old school liberals
and conservatives old school lefties as
well of course and Mark says who want to
talk about class and not identity and so
on
um and it's a it's a great you know it's
great coalition to be in
um it's it's a lot of fun I mean a lot
of my
you know if you if you told me that you
know five six years ago I'd be cheering
on gender critical there's been Marxist
feminists you know just and saying go
for it you know you're doing you're
fighting a tremendous battle and and
seeing myself as broadly you know
broadly aligned with our vision of of of
freedom and
um and reason and and the pursuit of
Truth and so on I mean I I don't thought
you were mad if I'd be you know if you
told me I'd be you know part part of an
alliance with them but but but what we
are where we are and I think that's a
it's it's an exciting time it's an
exciting time to be alive I imagine kind
of coming of age in the late 80s I mean
just how boring that would have been you
know it's an ability to pry property
there we go all of that stuff yeah well
I'm glad you enjoyed it
um but I'm curious I mean we we've
obviously talked about uh a lot of this
in the past and with you today
what color is your pill is the question
what do you see coming what does the
future look like according to Dr James
Orr well look I mean I I probably don't
share your kind of proximas optimism I
mean I think that this is well can I
sorry to interrupt you so early but can
I just adjust that because
I am not saying I have looked into the
future and what I see is this beautiful
post-work Utopia in which we all hold
hands and hold you know sing Kumbaya and
live happily ever after
I'm saying either it's that
or it's the end of Western Civilization
as we've come to conceive of it so let's
at least try and do that that's all I'm
saying I'm not saying I am an optimist
I'm saying it's like well you know this
is the fight we've got to fight because
this is what's happening and My worry is
if the fight is fought solely from the
perspective of work people or idiots we
can all agree on that but there's not
much we can agree on beyond that and
that is not a recipe for you know from a
sales point of view but it's not a great
sales technique the other guys is
not a great sales technique that's all
I'm saying yeah I apologize very very
helpful very helpful distinction and you
know I agree with you there's nothing to
disagree with there
um look I mean I did Classics at
universities so I mean I I you know I
love studying civilizations that that I
thought were amazing but that but that
faded and and vanished disappeared
um the Roman civilization lasted
um an unbelievably long time I mean in
in relative terms
um so civilizations you know spangler's
right civilizations have a certain sort
of life cycle
um and um empires have uh life cycle I
think um some people have calculated it
to roughly 250 years which would give
America another
three years
12 2026 midterms it wasn't quite an
Empire when it started so maybe we can
give them a bit more time maybe and it
would have certainly certainly emerge
from an Empire maybe but yeah so I I you
know it's um I think talk of white pills
and black pills and this sort of
talk is is not helpful partly because
you know I think there's an element of
contingency in how things as I said
earlier and how things unfold but we
should we should always factor in
um I'm a uh I'm a Christian so I and I
take the view that
biological death is not death and that
the human individual has a Transcendent
infinite value that you know it is of of
a kind that reduces the lifetime of
civilizations to nothing
um that's all very well for you
walk around right and before we do I I
wanna I mean you mentioned the lifetime
of civilizations do do you think this is
we're kind of on on the on the downslope
I I think it's hard to avoid that
conclusion for the time being I mean I I
do think you know it it may take a very
long time but the if the question is you
know have we passed our our Peak
I'd say yeah we we probably have and and
we may have passed it some time ago and
you know part of me thinks you know
barbarians are not at the gates they've
been in they've been in the city they're
Manning The Citadel they've been there
for quite a while so what happened in
Rome to a large extent they start to
turn corporate Barbarian tribes I mean
this is an interesting you know in
whatever it was August 410 A.D
um The Barbarians didn't you know
besiege Rome they strolled in uh they
walked in civilizations typically
destroy themselves from within they
become spent exhausted
um they are crippled by burdens that
they themselves have have generated it's
quite rare apart from who gengar's Khan
and it's quite rare for as it were
foreign foes external foes to come in
and sweep and Destroy Everything a
destroy a civilization just like that
they they die from within and I think
it's hard to avoid the sort of smell of
civilizational death
um at times and then very easy to get
pessimistic
um but uh you know as glorious as
Western Civilization has been it doesn't
have an automatic right to ascendancy it
has to be fought for and we've forgotten
how to fight for it or we got nervous
about fighting forage the other side the
side that thinks that that really
anything to do with Western Civilization
just is
he he is to be repudiated completely is
well organized it knows what it thinks
it may be statistically numerically in a
minority
but that you know doesn't really matter
as as we know it tends to be minority
Elites that can achieve massive massive
social cultural and political change and
I can't remember what it is but I mean I
don't want to compare them to the
Bolsheviks but think back to think back
to the you know 1917 the Welsh books
were tiny relatively small minority
um and I think we're seeing you know it
doesn't really matter what large sways
of the population actually believe and
in fact when you do a lot of the polling
on for example I don't know attitudes to
our Imperial past and attitudes to our
heritage or attitudes on you know sex
and gender and so on there's actually a
very mixed picture all very often clear
majority that is against
the sort of dominant Elite voices and
we've recognized this pattern again and
again but it doesn't seem to have any
effect and certainly The Ballot Box
doesn't seem to you know do much I mean
um uh it doesn't seem to affect much
change at all
um I mean there are signs I think here
and there maybe in the conservative
party at the moment
uh glimmers uh there are signs in the
United States and certain States in in
Florida and Texas and elsewhere there
are signs of some sort of
more organized
um
attempt to offer a an alternative vision
and a reasoned repudiation and critique
of
um of of you know of of the people who
are kind of
letting these acids drip through and and
and dissolving
um a sort of the settlement of of
Western civilization and and um you know
that that you know there may be reasons
to to be hopeful that they will kind of
staunch the you know staunch the flow
um who knows so I mean I'm broadly you
know in the near term pretty pretty
pessimistic in the long term look
there's there's a line of uh
Horus this great Roman Pearl I did Latin
part I studied at University as here's a
line um
uh the the that you can drive nature out
with a pitchfall but it's always going
to come rushing in through
through the back door
um so you know reality is a very good
Ally to have on your side
uh it's it's in the end you're going to
and and the more detached an ideology
becomes from
underlying from being in the more it
slips its Moorings
from the world from Human Nature in
particular
um the less sustainable it's going to
become
um and and just just the less
self-evident those ideological claims
are going to be that's why there's been
so much energy devoted to shutting down
free free speech and why you've had such
a kind of corrosive
attacks on on academic freedom because I
think the more radical an ideology gets
the less it can afford the open playing
field you know the the the sort of the
The Crucible obscrutiny in um uh in in a
kind of open and free
um Market Place of ideas yeah
James it's been an absolute pleasure uh
thank you so much for coming on the show
we always end with our final question
which is always the same which is what's
the one thing we're not talking about as
a society that we really should be
what's one thing that we're not talking
about my gosh that's a that's a very
good question
um well look I mean here's a this is
Bland and generic an answer but one of
the things where we're not talking about
is
um
what if what are the pre-political
sources of meaning that we can we can
share we can sort of draw on uh that
will help us Stitch ourselves together
in in into a flourishing Community we we
know that you know culture is has
started to dissolve we know that
politics is a no-go area religion is
complicated how do we find you know what
what are those
um what is the glue that the constituous
together
um and we're not asking that question
because you know it's very difficult to
ask it I mean and very very few people
have got have got the ideas
um hopefully that will you know emerge
over time
um and so it's not as concrete an answer
as bad maybe you were but it's exactly
the right answer for the moment I think
that's why I asked you this question
because because
I I if there is an answer it is going to
be produced by asking the question yeah
you know and the difficulty we face as I
think you're right to say is we don't
have much in answer to that at the
moment but I think
the reality is the the the solution is
within that answer to a lot of this
stuff and we're all you know those of us
who are thinking about this stuff we're
all going to have to agree on something
Beyond not liking the other people
that's just gonna have to happen yeah
and that may mean the the problem for a
lot of people particularly the sort of
more liberal of us is we don't like
telling other people what to do yeah
absolutely and once you get into the
Realms of you know it's family it's this
and it's that there's a there's a
there's a there's a hesitation there
that perhaps is a reflection of the fact
that
30 or 40 years ago there were a lot of
people going you must have a family and
none of us wanted to be told that
because we wanted to make our own
choices in life
um but maybe maybe there is an
opportunity to work out a more and this
is what Peterson and I talked about when
I was on his podcast is it has to be
sort of Invitational
enrolling it has to be like you don't
have to have a family you don't have to
do anything you're a free atomized
individual just like you believe however
if you want to have a good life here's
some of the things that people have
found in the past that do help you
towards that yeah maybe that's what it
looks like couldn't agree more read old
books trust old books trust all books
because you need to recognize that ideas
age in Reverse we get weaker as we get
older ideas get stronger as they get
older and there's a deep truth to that
when you're trying to implement a new
ideology energy you want historical
Ground Zero you want everybody to forget
the past it's all Wells Old Line whoever
controls the past controls the present
whoever controls the president controls
the future and all and all of that so
yeah read old books not on Kindle
um that that that would be I think that
would be you know Wise advice and and
don't don't neglect
um don't neglect wisdom of the past
[Music]
spoken like a true conservative uh Dr
James old before we let you go we're
obviously going to ask you a few
questions from our local supporters that
only they will get uh to see and I think
a lot of it is actually on the subject
we haven't talked too much about which
is religion because that is one of the
things obviously that you you you do
professionally uh before we let you go
where can people find your work online
and what would you like to them to know
about things coming up Etc thank you
well look I've just stepped into the
Bear Pit I've just stepped uh on to
Twitter my my handle is jtw or o double
r
um so you can follow me there I can't
promise uh great wisdom but uh at the
moment I'm busy uh announcing speakers
for this upcoming National conservatism
conference middle of May 15 16 17 May
2023 in Westminster uh sign up national
conservatives in UK you'll find all the
details on my on my on my uh on yeah my
Twitter profile and if you can bear it
you can inflict some of my academic work
on yourselves uh by going to my faculty
webpage at The Faculty Divinity
University of Cambridge
um the look for my name
Dr James oh thank you so much and thank
you for watching and listening we'll see
you on locals very shortly and for those
of you who like your trigonometry on the
go it's also available as a podcast take
care and see you soon guys
what evidence is there that the biblical
character we now know is Jesus Yeshua I
think is the way you pronounce it ever
actually existed
[Music]